Oh
Hello there I am so happy you're here because this is the part of the show where we thank you the ice cream truck drivers
Thank you so much ice cream truck drivers. We don't have a new list yet
We're recording this show in the past. There might be a new list by the time this show gets published
Otherwise, you're just gonna hear me saying this this is what you'll hear if we don't add the list in
I feel like that's right. Yeah, but let's go right here though. Yeah, this is where we would put it
It feels like we're if we had the list would put it right here
If you want to be an ice cream truck driver, and I sure hope you do preaching fun commas ring
Go preaching fun comm head over there sign up to be an ice cream truck driver and who knows?
The life you save may be your own
Hey Johnny, do you want to go to an ice cream social? Yeah, I'd love to great. Let's go
People in the chat about putting up pictures of their dogs. Oh, we've gone all the way down to just dog pictures on
It's time for Matt Mattingly's ice cream socials sitting over there and Las Vegas that's Matt Donnelly sitting in Pittsburgh
That's Paul Mattingly in Las Vegas. It's me Jacob the audio guy. We're preaching fun
Hey everybody, welcome gents, how we doing so many cute dogs
As we are
Airing this show we're airing from the past. I've had a birthday. I bet it went wonderfully
I had a little vacation. I bet it went wonderfully Matt. You're on the road non-stop right now. What's going on with you?
This I'm trying to think of what this is Aaron because I am doing this thing where I have to go to Chicago
Yeah, do one show and then get up the next morning and fly out to
St. Louis and then drive to a gig in Missouri two hours from the airport
Do a corporate show that's supposed to be blood money. So this will certainly come up on the show again
Yeah, because we a lot of drunk people go back to Chicago finish out of Chicago Magic Lounge where I'm gonna turn around
And then go home
For for the holidays and then after the holidays it go right back out. I got a corporate in South Bend, Indiana
whoa
And then I'll be heading to the jokers of magic after that, which I'm so excited about
And while you're in South Bend, are you going to air your grievances with the Notre Dame football team and their new?
Scheduling thing that they're gonna do with the college football playoff. That's a big part of your trip
It's gonna be wearing Miami shorts and Alabama sweatshirt
Just whistling, yeah
I'm also gonna be doing a comedy club in Chicago, which I have to get more details on but I'm one of the office
We have like one random off night
On the tour and Mike Mills arranged for us to give it give us a shot in a comedy club
Which I'm so excited about it's gonna be Chicago right the comedy club in Chicago
Which means it's for people out there who are near there. It's a little more affordable than the old
Chicago Magic Lounge, so
Hopefully you can come out and check out that this is part of the jokers of magic tour, right? Yes
So it'll be it'll be if me myself Mike Mills Eric Dittleman Ruben Moreland who I'm so excited
I don't think a lot of people know Ruben, but you will know and love him. I'm so excited to do the tour with him
Oh, very cool. He's very funny like a ball. We'll get him on the pod as well
Are all four of you gonna do the comedy club or is it? Yes, just know. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, also fun
So you guys you guys get to kind of write up stuff for a smaller stage then yes
Yeah, yeah, and I could do more crowd work and things like that that I'm excited about and
Yeah
My secret goal is to be comedy club worthy
This is why I'm trying to I'm trying to cajole Brian brushwood and to into maybe thinking about doing his first shows since 2010
He's done some shows here and there but he hasn't truly
Tored like going on done shows since 2010, which is a crime, right?
A crime a crime people who who like that guy and I think I think it's fine
This is here's here's my options as a as a pro, right? The jokers of magic. Hopefully this becomes a thing
It's a lot. It's a lot of heavy lifting right now to do any kind of live theater and any kind of live touring right now
Just for the for the people living in the middle to lower class. We are in a recession for people in the upper class
Hopefully they want to come see tours
That's where we're at that's where all of entertainment is at right now that is that is
Desperately true. Yeah, this is why concerts are crazy expensive is because there's enough rich people that that they can afford that
The sphere just put out numbers yesterday for what they what they say. They've made on the Wizard of Oz. Oh
And it's like two hundred million dollars. Yeah, and it's I mean it's it's still yes, and they're still in the red
But you know
So
You know when I try to think about like what I want to do
It's like I can try to produce my own shows and try to do like hotel hotel the hotel model where you do like
You team up with a fancy hotel you put like an awesome right together make it like a a wine and whatever and do that kind
Of stuff, but that involves a production value, which means like hauling things in
You know putting a pipe and drape and that kind of stuff and having a lighting package and an audio thing
And I was like, no, no, no. No. I love performing comedy clubs. I
think
This is me. This is I'm just this is the real deal. That's what I'm talking to my friends privately. Is that yeah
I think magic is a bigger addition of a factor to a comedy club
Then comedy is an addition as a factor to magicians in a theater. Does that make sense?
I I think you're absolutely right when I used to work at the Laugh Factory
every now and then a magician would come through and
Honestly for better or worse sometimes it would change the dynamic of the room completely
Yeah, and so when the magician came through and they were good. It was like, holy shit. This is great
This is built for this. Yeah, and when they came through and it was bad
They were like, oh this is this is supposed to be funny and it's terrible and that's it and that there is there's a there's a
There's a lot of there are cheeseball magicians out there doing cheeseball comedy
That puns and and I win you lose lines and that kind of stuff
That I hate so it's but that's so that's the obstacle
but I think like in terms of like where I think I can put my effort and prove to I can do something and
Where I think the show would be additive and where it doesn't attack my weakness, which is adding crazy
I'm not a good tech person. So adding crazy production values, not my strength. I
Think Amy at comedy clubs would be great. And then should it work? Should it work at all?
Then it's easy to add Paul. It's easy to add other acts to the lineups and stuff to make it an even crazier cooler
varietal of a show
But but this is this is in the meantime. I'm just bound to cruise ships. Well, they figure all this out
Yeah, yeah, and it's also a matter of just like you said before the timing of everything and where the country is financially
God bless Mike Mills. Mike Mills is trying to make sure the jokers of magic gives it a shot
He's trying to find smart ways for us to tour
It is an uphill battle for all tours right now and he runs a giant touring company
So when he says that he's talking he's talking with evidence about you know, 25 properties that he tore
Oh, yeah, you know like Mills entertainment, you know that with a John Candy documentary was touring with
with different guests high-end guests, you know like
Talking about John Candy and people worked with him and Ryan Reynolds was hosting all that
That was Mills entertainment, right? You might have even seen tik-toks and stuff with the stand by me cast
The whole stand by me cast is reunited. Yes. They're starting that is that is that one of his
Yeah
So it's a brilliant idea by the way, that's it. So they're being very nice. He's locking into some good stuff there
They've always been very innovative
With their touring and they've and they've always been really cool stuff
But he has data when he says it is a crazy slog right now to be trying to fill get both the seats in theaters
He means it and so I am feeling very fortunate that he is putting me in the mix
But that's our thing that should property and that's it
I think that we are trying to make this viable, you know
put some butts in seats and with the idea that we're playing a long game of
Trying to make this a thing that happens semi regularly
Until the economy kind of turns around for some people and we can go go go actually bring it to the people in a regular way
Yeah
I mean, I remember 2008 that's what I had to do, you know boats boats kept me going for
nine months
right basically a year I had to be away for a year to
Keep it cooking with the same kind of financial realities that were around for entertainment. It's crazy times
So all had to sell boats. Let's get into whether or not Mike Mills is a fool for relying on me
So I am was finishing up show. I have a guess
I was finishing up shows in on the princess cruise ship and I the last day of the cruise
Not disembarkation day, but the day before here our last day at sea as we were heading towards Florida
Okay, I locked myself out of my room. I
Told the story on Penn Sunday school, but you know Penn just kind of laughed at me and then you know
I figured it can get more mileage here
and it's also I told Penn we recorded the day that it happened and
Now we're we're a week and change later and I'm still still processing so it's worth bringing up again because I'm still oh my
so I
Get online, but you okay to get back into my room and
It's a long line. So we said like you don't want anything to go wrong in the last day of the cruises because that's the day
We're everyone. There's so much stuff going on with people getting stuff approved. Oh like a customer service line
Yes, yeah, you're waiting in a customer service line to get a key to get back into your room
Yes, and that's the day I was wondering why there was a line in front of your room to get back in. Oh, sorry
No, no, thank you for you probably clarifying for the service as well. Good job and
You're at customer service everybody's at customer service because it's the end of the cruise and everybody is I'm sure very happy with all of the
Accommodations and things that they have paid for on the cruise and they are there to tell customer service just how happy they are, correct
Good, and so I'm it's I'm online. It's like I was like I blew it
I had my headphones with me because I like myself because I'm gonna go to the gym and I and I like my headphones and not
My key so I'm listening to podcasts for like 20 minutes
And then I finally get to like on deck before I go to my little desk
And there's a circle of desks waiting for people or about like, you know, six different customer service people
Okay of these desks you kind of you got to answer like a lollipop you come up you're online
I'm picturing a circular room. Yeah. Yeah, and then I
Take off my headphones
Cuz I'm on deck getting ready to rock. Okay, and about six feet to my right is a guy complaining about
His bill on spellbound, which is the name of the Magic Castle experience that I'm a part of
He was like I did not mean to tip the magician
So much money I meant to tip the magician several hundred dollars
But I tipped them too many hundreds of dollars so I need I need some of that money back from the magician so I can get
Home that's that's what the whole problem was. Yeah. Look, it's a big experience and you know, you can
It's it's a bunch of people like coming around and so like, you know
Who knows which part of the experience he wasn't happy with, you know, okay drinks could have been the whatever
And then he starts saying like yeah, the magician was just terrible
Okay
This guy has gone to a customer service representative on a cruise ship
To talk about a show that this customer service representative
Certainly hasn't seen he wants his drinks taken off of his bill
He doesn't want to pay for the drinks. He doesn't want to pay for the drinks because the entertainment was not great. That's right
Okay
Huh? This is a schemer and I'm on the other end of that when I go see a show and the entertainment is not great
I am more reliant on the drinks than I usually
Those are the shows that I do not dare complain about the drinks. Yeah, and
I am like, well, there's two magicians. Maybe he's complaining about the other magician
Then of course he was
Okay, I did
26 shows on this last run on princess. Okay, 26 shows in one week
Over seven days. Yeah
Wow, okay. Sometimes that's it. That's multiple shows a day. Sometimes for 30 people sometimes for two
Okay, that's the deal
It was a shift recently right where normally it was always for 30 some odd people
It was always a always a that they wouldn't give me a show unless they packed the theater
But right they change the way the experience works and how who can sign up for it and when and so you kind of have to
Take people as they come and you end up yeah, he goes for people. So it's really weird to give a theatrical
Magic experience to eight people. Yes
however
One day goes he goes. Yeah, I mean, you know he started off with like, you know
You can't someone take a card that he found the card like who can't do that. That's what he said to the person type
Yeah, who can't do that?
Wait, who can't do that? He did not start going through
Individual aspects of your show. He sure did Jacob. He sure did to the customer service rep. Yes
Who was not asking for any details whatsoever? She was typing. She was like, hey
Okay, what do you need? Let's see if I can do it. Yes, and so there's she was not asking for details
So it was clear that he had like for hers this in his head, right? Oh
He was getting out like his speech, you know
Yeah
And so warming up by the way, so that my opening trick that I do in the smaller environments is I have someone look at
An envelope I put in my pocket
They take a card they sign it. I
say I
Haven't put in the back of the deck. I put a side in the back of the deck to shuffle it
And I say where's the envelope and they go in your pocket and I reach my pocket all the cards are in my pocket
Then they literally look back to my left hand which was previously holding all the cards and it's holding an envelope
And it said the envelope is their card and it is signed by them. Okay, anybody can do that
Anybody can do that anyone can do that. So I was offended at his description of my opening
You should be
You're right to be offended by that gave him a piece of my mind. Now. Look, you know, I'm a human
I'm a self-conscious human, you know, I'm a thing. I'm a we've established on this podcast. I'm a thin-skinned human
I do not don't be me to Matt. He'll be up. It'll upset it
So at first I really think to like hide
Like I literally go like oh my god, like how embarrassing like I literally almost pull my hat like over my head
Are you you're still in line at this point or you're a different desk, okay, right so you're in line, but he is but he's being
Serviced by the customer service people. That's right
Okay, and if you were across the room, I wouldn't hurt it. And if I had not locked my key of my door
I would never known about it
Then I'm called I have something to say about the magic show quote-unquote that I watched
And I am
You know
Did you put your headphones back in surreptitiously
No, I really had a voice go off in my head. That was like as if like I was parenting myself
I literally go like don't you dare don't you dare and I do not interact
No, no, but I was like don't hide like I was like, okay
I literally got self-conscious put my head over my head and the voice went on my head was like no
Fuck him, right?
And so I went full like I like total split personality went full aggro
Then I put my head back and I started standing tall and I started staring at him. Oh
Okay, but you haven't spoken to it I haven't spoken to him and then he complains about a second trick
Oh boy
He's gonna go through the whole routine he's got notes I did 26 shows
and
25 of them every trick went amazing. Oh
buddy and 26 shows I did six effects on his show
One trick went wrong
Okay, and it was my ring trick and it was like not to be too magic about it
but I and I've performed this trick a lot and
There was a design factor in this ring that I did not understand and therefore
The magic effect did not work and I authentically lost their ring in a sea of rings
Jar you have like a mason jar of rings, right?
Yes, and I pull the ring out of a pile of rings and it's their ring on a string
Yeah, and due to a certain design of the ring the ring did not come up with a string
and
Legitimately a pile of rings. Yep
Good and as reminded of what Penn says about magic, which is when match tricks go wrong boys
it's just a waste of everyone's time and
And now I feel
Less emboldened as an ogre staring him down because now he's calling you out on an actual
He has a point very rarely
Our magicians held to account
Strictly by the success of their tricks and yet here I am
Costing this company money
For failing to do my job. Are they refunding his money? They are
That they are they are funding his drinks there. Let's make this loud man happy enough that he will go away
They're we're funding it before he was giving any details
They didn't care or want the details didn't even care why he didn't like spellbound
They just be said I did not enjoy spell and I went off
They said okay, and then while she was trying to work it out on her computer. He just started rallying it off
Yeah, yeah, he slowed her down telling her the things that were wrong with him
So then I get called to my customer service desk and it's the one right next to him
I don't get called across the room. I get called
This makes me so happy and that's that was Penn's response that's exactly that's all pended
Penta's laughs and said this is great
He's right he's right that's right
And now I'm sitting next to him and I basically I'm like now I'm like like ready to give the sup chin to him
Cuz like yes, it's me whatever
Now I'm dressed to go to the gym. I'm basically dressed like the way I like to be
The whale of the chat slowly I turned
And so I'm in like, you know t-shirt or my my my flat cap I got headphones around my neck and I'm in
you know, you know sweatpants and
He just doesn't recognize me straight up just looks
Just looks at me and goes no and I'm staring at him right like a little angrily staring at him. I'm making eyes with him
He he doesn't realize this but he's already been having a conversation with you
he interprets my staring eyes as
Boy, doesn't it suck to be stuck in customer service right now
So I give him a glare and he looks at me sees my glare and puts his hand on my shoulder and says
We'll get through this
Oh
Multiple levels that we'll get through this is working on my brain. I
Like scob smacked. I am speechless. I am spinning
This is wild that's fucking wild this is the most magical thing that happened on that cruise
Was like I am so like
I want to tell no one right? Like this is so embarrassing. I don't know if I could tell my wife about this
Right
And then I'm like and then I literally have to go to the 19th deck and take a walk. That's what I do
I literally go like I got a harpooners run stand by
Man the harpoons this guy looks like a jumper
I'm like all the woulda coulda shoulda's and everything else and then all sudden going like but you did fuck up your trick
And I was really spinning and then I was like, oh, huh, I'm gonna tell Penn and Penn
Tell pencil this goes. Yeah, I could tell nobody I can tell, you know 20,000 people and
And then Penn just left his ass off and then I just been processing it but I just was like
Really? I really ran myself with a ringer for like a good couple hours and I thought I was like I
Was really like I'm quitting magic. I'm
People people don't this is behind the curtain right here
This is more behind the curtain than we usually go when Matt messes up like a patreon post or something. He beats himself up
Matt does not like making mistakes on things especially ones that he could have avoided
It's so the fact that this guy is being an asshole and you're like in your mind. You're like, oh this fucking jerk
He's being a he's being a jerk and he's being a jerk about my thing and that sucks and man
This guy's really being a jerk shit. He said something that's correct. I I did mess that up
And he is just he is correct. I don't have a firm fuck that guy
I'm great at telling someone else fuck that guy, right?
You're like this guy did this to me. I'm great at like getting in my friends faces and be like hey fuck that guy
You know and really getting the person to like really shed it, you know, yeah, it does not work on me. I cannot do it
Can't do it. I'm the child of a public defender. I literally like, you know, it's like oh my god that murder my brain goes
Well, it came from somewhere. What was his childhood? Like who did what he do? You know, like I this is what I grew up
Seeing the three-dimensionality of life's horrors through the New Jersey criminal justice system
I always try to give someone credit even if they're being full dickheads to me, right?
Oh, if I can take a part of it as blame, I will shovel that blame onto my own shoulders
Speaking of taking blame. I don't think we discussed how did the rest of the ring trick go after the mechanism didn't work?
Great question
What is the solution there I literally have to go in front of the audience and peel through all the rings to
And find it and return it to them
oh
So you don't just like take the table off stage and hand it to a stage hand like with the couple and be like
Help these people find their ring. I now yeah, I have no stage hands on spellbound on my regular
If I was on the main stage of her cruise ship I could do exactly what you just said
But yeah, it's spelled like here's the couple whose ring I just lost please find the ring for them and send them back to their
See, man, I really only have one question Matt. Yes. I really have one question
After you have to scatter the rings out and go through them bit by bit
Yeah
And slowly but surely disseminate the junk rings and find the one when you do finally find it
Do you at least give a tada?
Did you do a flourish when you found?
Don't do that Paul I don't do that
I'm gonna say missed opportunity missed opportunity. I
It's funny. I I think it's cuz I you know came up through Penn and Teller Penn and Teller don't have
Women we're relaunching the show and we were working with Jeff McBride and Jeff McBride was you know is a famous magician his own
Right a huge huge magician runs a magic school here in Las Vegas the most famous one of the most famous magic schools in the world
Jacob no Paul rather
This I don't think I could be more accurate this metaphor even though this will go over most of the audience's head
He is the Sharna Halpern of magic
Yeah, yeah, Jeff is yes Jeff McBride is yeah one-on-one ratio Sharna Halpern ran Improv Olympic and all the things that okay bitch
About Sharna about people bitch about Jeff about and all the power that trying to had Jeff has
great
but he he they he was hired as a consultant to help relaunch the show post-pandemic and I was in the room with him and
At one point they were doing it going over a trick and
Jeff McBride goes well, what's your out on that and this is an out is like magicians basically like what's your thing?
If you miss it you go back and you get it later. Uh-huh. What's up that fucks up? What's your what you're out?
Yeah, and they both turned to Jeff and go like we don't have outs
And he goes what do you mean you don't you don't have it out for this he goes no we don't have outs we don't use outs
Because you live outside any tricks and they go no
It works or it doesn't they go. What do you think? Oh, we just move along
Right and this made Jeff laughs like so hard
He's like, what do you think you don't have outs and I was laughing I go, you know, it's funny Jeff
I haven't worked with them there for years. They don't
And a teller don't yeah use outs
They just go like that didn't work and they go what that's next next and so
I
Comedically point out how much authentic sweat was piling up on my forehead as I
Went through the rings in a jar until I found their ring and then said I could try to do something magical
Here to try to make this an out and make this not a mistake
But I think just funny to let you guys know that I made a mistake and we're moving on and I got a big laugh
And then I finished the show strong with two more effects. And so I thought I had recovered the show as a whole
Beautifully well, and I think was proved 95% of your audience did think that oh
That's because you have not heard about the people that were in line behind that the rest of the crowd was in line behind Matt
You can they also didn't recognize him, but they had things to say. No, you can't make all everybody happy
It's just what it is. Oh man. No time. It was on the same ship
We were doing I did end up doing a show for two people and it was so awkward
So the next group that came oh my show for two people. I said listen, you're doing shows at the you're doing tricks at the bar
I go let me just switch off with you at the bar. We'll just do all of our tricks. Oh, yeah
They go great
And so we he and I
entertained two people and two people left over at the bar going back and forth doing tricks and end up getting real kind of energy in
There's really fun. And I love all sudden. I was like man. I love doing magic behind the bar. This is really fun
Yeah, those people complained they didn't get the theatrical experience and got money for fuckers
They got the intimate special one-of-a-kind thing and they're like I didn't like that
It's just cuz they can this cruise ships. I'm gonna say this is cruise ship. This is this is that is that is these are the people
That are on the cruise ship already that I like that's the thing is you you are just this is gonna sound like I'm being mean
To you, but I'm not
This is the thing where you are just in their mind one of the things that's like a box that they can tick
They're like, yep. I think I get my money back on that one. I'm pretty sure I can get my money back on this like
Oh, I got I ate at this restaurant. It's a little more than eating the buffet, but you know, the steak was overcooked
So I'm gonna go ahead and get my money back on that man
I never had to go through hearing or seeing any kind of critique on my
Stuff it shows when we were doing well
Again so again because I'm part of this boutique experience right through the Magic Castle. It's not a regular thing
So on a regular ship, I am ushered on through the entertainment, you know, I'm greeted by the you know, the the the entertainment director
I'm handled with my you know tech and all the run-throughs and all this other stuff and I will never hear anything on those ships
So the regular ships that I do this is a premium
Experience. Yes. It's the only thing people can pay for an additional cost. Yes, and therefore they cop people who that makes a fucking difference
They you know that kind of stuff. Oh sure. Yeah, and so you deal with all kinds of and oh
I didn't even think about you still get casino comps on the ocean. Yes, you can't get away from get the casino comps and
Once my first day once I'm ushered onto the ship
that's the last time I see an entertainment director until the end of the ship from then on I am under the
jurisdiction of the restaurant manager and catering Oh
Yes, and those people are not an entertainment and so they know they tell you things very plainly the way no entertainment director ever would
So that's how I found out about the theater experience thing
No
And I like an entertainment director an agent nobody else nobody in the entertainment world is telling you about that at all
No, and even what time I end up not not without a lot of sugar
I did know not doing one of my five shows when I supposed to because I was told
By someone else that it was not gonna be for like another half hour
So I went okay
I went I left the theater and I got yelled at yell that like I was
Like a like a bartender like like working for them
Yeah, and it was like looking at them like what I'm like, I why are you you cannot?
Like why are you yelling at me? And right I?
Was like I said I said I said just as you know, I wait till it calm down. I gave it a beat
I did my show I went back to them and I said just so you know, I never leave
The room unless it's set for a show. So the moment you want to show you can have it
I said all I've done this entire week is say yes
I've never said no to a single thing. So you tell me the shows are I'm doing six shows tonight
I'm doing four shows tonight. I'm doing two shows. I'm doing a show for two people
I'm doing a show for 30 people all I have said the entire time was yes
So please don't treat me like I'm some guy sneaking off to like slack and right
Yeah, that's not what I'm doing
I said so you can just shoot me a text saying need you now and you will have a show that starts in a minute
And I was like, that's all you need to know
And it's just like you can't
Basically what I couldn't say was like you can't yell at a performer and expect them to be very good at this
right
You're lucky you're talking to someone who has an experienced bartender and experienced catering waiter and experienced mater day
Yeah, you've been in that you've been in that world long enough to know what it is. But boy, that's what I was
By the way, it's somebody who's gone through enough therapy to not like scream back at her
She's yelling at you in the first place. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Lindsay Bashir is right. I said I was a waiter and I cried
Tears from the eyes, but I was like and this is all you know, and this is it's it's just a strange thing
It's a strange gig that I looked into it's a weird bit
and the strange bit is is it pays slightly better than the
Than if I was a main stage performer performing for all thousand people at the same time in the theater, right doing two shows in a cruise
What I'm doing because I'm working seven nights a week and doing three or four sets a night actually pays better
So even though this is shittier and it's less glorious and I don't feel like an entertainer as much as I feel like a high-end
bartender waiter
Okay, it's still worth it to do it for my family to do to do the experience. Yeah, man
I mean at least you feel like a high-end bartender. It's true. I'm gonna talk to you could could be a low-end bartender
I'll tell you who loves a good low-end bartender and by that I mean bartending on their ends and that's the following sponsor
Today's show is brought to you by
Sorry, I brought the jokers of magic dates and then where did it go? Oh, here we go
Today shows brought to you by Brian brushwood and Justin Robert Young's greatest hits volume two
That's right. Today's show is brought to you by Brian brushwood and Justin Robert Young's greatest hits album volume two
Hey everybody, it's Brian. Hey, I'm here with the
scams cool
Look, I know I know what you want. I know what you want to trick your friends. You want to trick your neighbors?
You want to trick your kids? Well, you can't
I'm about to show you a secret. This is a deep dark secret
Picture it
1958 a
Young American sailor just got done with a tour of near Cambodia
He decides that he's gonna go for a swim. Yeah
so he puts on some fins a
snorkel mask and dives
He dives just outside of one of the Cambodian islands as deep as he can go with a single breath
While he's down there in the ocean depths. He comes upon
a mollusk
inside this mollusk he later discovers a pearl a
Perfect pearl or what he assumes to be a perfect pearl
So he takes that pearl out of the mollusk and
Thinks on it. He's looking at this beautiful gem that was created inside the gut of this squiggly little animal that lives
inside of a collapsed shell
He thinks to himself. I bet if I made a bunch of these I
Could really make a business
Sure enough
He looks into the deed for that area of beach and it just happens to be for sale
And the price of that beach happens to be almost exactly
His four months furlough salary that he was receiving from a GI bill
So he decides to take a risk he buys that small piece of beach off of Cambodia
and he starts seeding all of these
mollusks all around this seabed and
creating pearls and
He turns this into a business
It takes a couple of months for the pearls to be created
He brings them up
takes the pearl
Puts many of them right back into the water. They keep breeding
He's making conditions down there that are very affable to how they live. He feeds these mollusks
He's got a real farm going
It's incredible
By 1963 he has an empire built on this small island
He's the king. He's ruling this place with his trade in pearls
He can't believe his luck. How lucky can you get the pearl magnate of?
South Cambodia this guy he's got everything he needs
But then he finds one of these mollusks
Has left its normal shell and gone into a very fancy spiral one
He crafts this spiral shell
and he looks inside and
He pulls out the mollusks that he's seeded and sure enough
There's a pearl in there more perfect than any other pearl
He keeps this shell and he keeps reseeding it over and over again
and
that shell
Becomes the new holy grail for his enterprise
he can't get better pearls than what he finds in this shell and
that's because
this man
after six years of farming pearls has found
the world's
greatest conk
I am so mad for so many reasons
I
Don't care what you do
Nick in the chat says I'm mad at myself for invested. I wasn't this I honestly didn't even know where it was going for a
Long time. Oh you really I thought I was gonna make a pearl necklace joke for a minute and then I finally went
Oh, yeah world's greatest. No world's greatest conk. Yeah
That's funny Matt and I both knew you're going there before you did yeah
That was a true cliff-diver
Thank You Leon
Constant fools because we're stupid cunks fools because we're human
By the way, they just did a banger of a new episode on the Ponzi scheme. Oh
Yeah, I've got to listen. Oh and world's greatest. I'm saving it. Yeah. Oh good. Yeah, he's only got the first episode up, right?
I mean, I think it's a one. I believe it's just a one-off. Oh, it's just a one-off. Okay, gotcha
Yeah. Yeah. Oh good. I've got a I've got plane flights this week
I need some good shows
But yeah
I'm sorry Paul has distracted us from everything that we might have been thinking about
Being a suffering cruise ship
But now all I can think about is world's greatest cock when I speak with such glowing enthusiasm for my upcoming jokers of magic gigs you now
You really understand why?
Really just I'm so excited to do real shows for real people and real environment away from that that structure. Yeah, that's a hard structure
cruise ships are
They can be a nightmare. It's
Their own this is their own world. There's just a strange that's there on the world. Yeah, I don't I don't begrudge it
I don't I think I think it keeps a lot of people employed in a lot of levels
A lot of brother I did for me. Yeah, I know I had a conversation this week with an old friend of mine
who works for Royal Caribbean and and that's what he was saying he was because he's kind of the
When new cast members and new entertainers are coming in
he's the one that's dealing with a lot of these these new people and
He's like yeah
The first two three weeks is just me telling them to trust me that it's all gonna work out this way
It's all a dumb system that they don't understand yet, but eventually they'll understand the dumb system and it'll be fine
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and yeah, it's just like it's this whole different thing. That's not like anything else in especially not an entertainment
Yeah, it's it's you know
and so actually when I'm talking about with with Penn is that like
For other things it makes a lot of sense, but in in entertainment you already already you already speak a currency of immediate gratification, right?
You showed up in the theater you laugh you applaud you leave with a smile on your face or
Or those things don't happen and you very much understand that those things didn't happen and you need to make adjustment, right?
You need to figure things out
So you don't need this additional
Threat of a future feedback loop that's going to hurt your reputation down the line
As you talk from one person to another I don't know
I mean you thought the rest of the show went really well is what you said
I mean, it sounds like you might have needed this extra feedback. I don't know
Maybe he just didn't think you look you looked ashamed of yourself enough
By the end of the show
Jessica Jane Peterson has been doing the the Lord's work. She's trying to get me on booked on Disney cruises, right?
that's that's her goal is to get me booked on Disney and
By we have the same agent and
So an opportunity came up at at Disney
He knew that there was a goal and he fired off my stuff to Disney and he fired off my usual stuff
Just sent them what he sends everyone. Yeah is not what you want to do to sell stuff to Disney Disney now
and so
And so I got
Rejected I got I got no he does not seem like he is he is gonna be a good fit on the ship
What's that opening monologue you do about all of your experiences at Disney parks that I think really might have turned him off?
That one experience, oh you guys like Disney do you
This is this is way before Splash Mountain this is more like Trash Mountain
And so
You know like I I was like they said the feedback and I was like, oh well if you set them my usual tape
Then yeah, I agree with I agree
You had a you had a different thing ready to go I don't know I did a cleaner show
With children in the theater
At Dickens in Delaware that I had an hour-long tape of that. It wasn't 45, but it was certainly more now
I still did my straightest jacket escape, which is which is one of their notes of like you could not cannot do that
I'm right. Okay. Well then fuck them
You don't want to work for them. Anyway
But if you did
My suggestion going forward Matt would that would be that you adopt a fursona. Ah
I would say I heard fursona and the answer is yes
Sona I see Jessica Jane, you know, and she's able to very quickly just
slide into
Disney Princess mode
You need to go full sully and you need a full furry outfit
Head to toe listening go on and and that needs to be the character that you create for these various
Particular child-friendly Disney s gigs. You need a persona magic routine. Why would Matt dressing up as a commercial airline pilot?
Excite these children
No, why would they care about that at all monsters already sullys that I landed a plane at a river
Yeah, yeah. I know but a love to do magic as sully. I would love to do it
I would do that so fast as sully that the be really funny to do it as the airline pilot
Yeah, it would be the hero of the Hudson. Yeah
The magic of sully sullenberger. I go to do a levitation and a bird strike hits
This child will be in the Hudson and I was gonna land this I'm gonna land this
Routine in the Hudson, but yeah, I think you could do you could do a full
You know and you could talk with you could talk with Harry the Gorilla Gition because he's got experience with that
He's basically taking on a fauna for magic. So, you know, I
Didn't watch a recent
Paul I don't know if you've been keeping up with fool us
But I watched a recent fool us episode and there was a fella on there that I laughed really hard at his routine
Before I realized what was happening
He does like like film work and stuff and he came out and did a very interesting avant-garde
Magical routine was this the body had a man? Yes. Yes boy that routine
I was sitting there looking at it going like how the fuck does this guy travel a buffalo head and then I realized that he
Just doesn't this was a one-off thing
That was the strangest thing we had ever done unfool us. Yep, and
When it was over, we had no better explanation
Penn and teller didn't know like how to even bust what they were watching, right?
But I don't think you fooled us
Also, I don't know what you just did
Cool. There's some interactive like film to life elements, which I guess qualify as illusion
there was there was this whole thing where part of it relied on Brooke going in and out of
The film. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. She was a character
Yes, and they didn't have anything the outfit that she needed to go in and out to make it really believable and
Seamless or at least a little more seamless
It was close, but I we ended up doing a ball was there
We end up doing like heavy lifting by we I mean the production team the production team did a lot of work to get that
Thing to get to get that to where it was
They ran through it at least for at least three times so there's a lot and and then the ending I like four times
There's everyone in the audience feel like they're just tripping balls. Yeah. No, that was just it. Everybody was like what the fuck is going on
I mean, I just watched it on TV and I was still tripping but nobody hated it
It was it was interesting enough that everybody was still polite and chill with it
So, you know, that's what the guy after Matt and line said to his customer service representative about Matt show. Mm-hmm
I hated it. Hey, everybody's polite enough
Head was interesting. I wish I was wearing a big buffalo head while I was sitting in customer service
This is what I'm telling you Matt you get you need a second fursona
So that when things go south on the ship, you can just put on a mask and fuck all these fools
Yeah, I don't know. I'm just sully I
Had to come up with a unique character
Sully Sullenberger the
Magic performing airplane pilot is pretty good character kind of ridiculous actually
Yeah, that's the thing. Yeah, so I'll try to try the Sullenberger thing
I did I did think of what we talked about moving the baseball cards to Marvel characters, which I think that would work
all right, right and
You know
JJ, of course, you're still like no we can figure it out
We just have to you know, whatever and I'm just like I don't know if this is worth chasing
Well, did you just hear yesterday's big announcement from them know how they're doubling down with AI
Who I don't even know what them you're talking about Disney, okay, it's really it's fucking weird
Because they had a lawsuit pending
Against a lot of these AI companies
Where they were they were winning in court a lot of times about misuse of their and misappropriation of their characters
And they have turned on a fucking dime and not only have they decided to allow these companies full access to their characters
But they are making investments in the millions and billions of dollars into said companies
So yeah, I mean this somebody got in somebody's bossy bossy just put one up in the chat here
It says Disney's got about a one billion dollar investment with a B with open AI
It's bring hundreds of Disney characters to its generative AI platforms, right?
So that is a that is a shift that is a policy shift over a huge shift a huge shift and it's not it doesn't bode
Well, but it's also just one more thing where we're just propping up this bullshit that doesn't do anything
Except let Sully fuck Mike Wazowski in the ass
You know like oh great
Yeah
Yeah, how how fun I get to watch Cinderella and essentially like Pixar has always had like a
Not even a hand in relationship with Disney, you know
Yeah, and Pixar just announced or do they decide to go the other way and they went back to doing a hand-drawn animation
The next the next the next movie coming out Sandra on and I think they're right to do it
like I
Here's here's the thing. Is that like?
In terms of like not trying to be doom and goomba AI, but also not liking some of the things I'm seeing I came up with
a metaphor
For myself were like I consider it like cooking
Okay, like okay figured out how to cook everything by machine and then our lives we see things that are by
Cooked by machine and we don't pay a lot for it and we don't care that much about it, right?
So we get fast food burgers from from you know
There's places and then it has not stopped us from craving better burgers
And then we've only turned around and respected people who are doing things more bespoke to make food taste good
So we we regularly pay people to do the expert things that at a level that we just simply don't want for machines
Right and bespoke nachos are the superior nachos way to kick with torpedo my point Jacob
No, no, but I mean this is like I think like yes great all these people are gonna be allowed to make all of their own
Disney movies and all that's gonna make us do is not give a shit or want to pay for those things
I'm not pay good money for those things
We might still consume it like we do all consume fast food
But we won't sit around raving about how we need to pay good money for this shit. It's clearly going to become
overall a devaluation of all of it, but I don't they're not I don't think they see that yet and I don't know I
Don't know that matters. So there's also a part of me and this is real
There's a part of me that's thinking like maybe it needs to be devalued a little bit
Absolutely. Well, the whole thing is just strange. Anyway, it has gotten away from itself, but
Yeah, the descendant of Walt Disney is always speaking up at shareholders meetings
Talking about how they'd be more generous and how they're portraying all these other things. It's it's a weird time
Yeah
Because all these things only in only in regards to Disney though. Everything else is going smoothly
But for Disney, it's an odd time in history right now, but that was a very freaky turnabout
from a huge creative company and I think you're okay for not
Being accepted by a company whose standards are clearly in limbo right now
Yeah, I mean look I have you know over the years where I almost got a job at ESPN and ESPN was bought by Disney or I?
my you know, my kids go to Disneyland for free because my
Mother-in-law's a retired employee
You know, don't get me wrong. I do a lot of back-and-forth at this about my relationship to the Disney as a company and investment
I mean I have we all do
My Toy Story stuff down there and you know, yeah
Yeah, I mean I loved Aladdin and Little Mermaid and Lion King. Although that was very formative stuff
Oh, we used to go to Disneyland Park, but we'd go there like 10 11 12 times a year easily
We'd just pop over there and just do a day and it's incredible
Yeah, you know like that that experience in those parks is incredible, right? It's expensive and incredible
That's the thing is now it's now it's fucking expensive
Expensive now. It's like holy shit. What are you guys doing prohibitive? Yeah, we go, you know for for free and it's expensive
Yeah, like like just just they make you add on all the stuff that pay for all the extra extra stuff
You don't just want like dinner. Yeah, it's like get a good dinner
Yeah
But I'm saying like this is this this is what this is what's gonna happen with AI is it's just gonna make it's just gonna make
The the waters muddier and it's gonna make real creators stand out and because it's gonna be a relief
More than just it's difficult
I'm sure you guys are doing the same thing like like scrolling on YouTube or on any social media thing on Instagram or whatever
Oh, it's so crazy just in this last couple of weeks there every every videos like it seems like the majority of the videos that
Are coming through now are AI something. Yeah, and and if we weren't
media savvy
We won't even be questioning it. Well, like I saw one the other day that was you know, some some left-leaning
Political organization put out a photo of Trump with the with the wind blowing his hair in a certain way
That made it look like he was completely bald and had a big comb over now
Donald Trump has famously has hair that looks like cotton candy made of piss
I'm not defending Donald Trump's hair, but I looked at this picture for about half a second was like this is photoshopped
Somebody is somebody's photoshopped this picture to make him to make him look worse than he does
Also, why waste your fucking time making Donald Trump look worse than he actually looks you don't need to it's but like
What are you doing? And I see that I go instantly we go like well, that's fake
moving on but not everything the scary thing is like you've got like videos of
People falling over and dropping shit and then you go. Oh, okay
They've got an extra arm or or oh that that little piece came out of nowhere
I but it won't be long before you can't discern
No, and that's the dangerous thing is that they're gonna use it as a propaganda tool
That's why they're pushing it so hard is to try and get it to better itself to the point where you can't discern
truth from fiction and then and then
like
I've seen I've seen good damn bands on this. So people are selling online
You can do the print model of a ring that you put it on your hand and it's an extra finger, right? Oh
It's great. You make sure you wear that if you're going to protest or if you're gonna be in any kind of compromising situation
Or just wear it day to day and any photos taken of you
You can then point to that and go like it's clear. It's clearly AI
There's an extra business right digit. Oh
I love using analog technology to defeat the the AI technology
But that's also like if you're a murderer, you're gonna start wearing extra fingers
Listen murderers have been ahead of technologies curve for many years. I guess you're right, but jeez, it's scary
Who else has been ahead of murderers for a long time, maybe not long enough. We'll see that's the following sponsor
Today's show is brought to you by become your inner champion
guided meditations by macho man Randy Savage become your inner champion
Hey, how's it going everybody? I'm so glad you joined me
Let's go ahead and pour ourselves a small glass of chamomile and bring it down to zero
Yeah, all the way down to zero. That's what I'm talking about. Calm
Relax yourselves. Okay. Let the tension flow out of your body
All the way down your toes. Oh, yeah
And then let it slip out through your shoes and into the carpet where it goes away and dissipates completely
I want you to clear your mind clear your mind
Think about all the little stars in the sky and all the little twinkling lights
Imagine that you're in a you're in a field and you're laying in the grass
Look good up at the sky and you're seeing nothing but stars. Oh, yeah, just stars everywhere you can look
There's no stars are twinkling you focus on one
Star one star
That you can see
It starts to get bigger and it's bigger and it's glowing and you are getting closer to that star
Closer to that star and it's getting bigger and it's slowly absorbing you
Becoming one with that star you are that star now
Yeah, you and the star the same thing no difference. We're all made of star stuff
Even miss Elizabeth made a star stuff. We're all the same. There's no separation. There's no me. There's no you there's just us
We're all connected in this big crazy world
And we're all here just for a cup of coffee on the planet earth and then poop we zip out of existence
Real fast, huh? Oh, yeah. What happened? What we do? Who do we help? That's all that matters
Who did we love? I loved miss Elizabeth and cocaine that was all
For the benefit of you you the people I tell you who I didn't love
Horkhogan fuck that guy
Those are specifically a great meditation very peaceful
Okay. Yeah, take it to zero. Okay
Let's do a little junk versus nerd where Paul score is gonna be zero
Today from winter scoop. I'm sorry not a scooperty a handmade jock versus nerd scoop categories
Scoopagories is the name of this game Jacob is the game master
There will be six rounds the master will read one word or phrase at a time the player who buzzes in first gets to guess
What the category? Oh what category all the words connect to it?
so I'm gonna give you a word or a phrase read some words phrases one one word at a time and
You're gonna tell me what the category is if they get it wrong
The other player gets a free guess before the next one is read it gets easier the more that are read if nobody guesses it
Correctly Jacob gets to make fun of you for as long as he sees fit Wow
And as always Jacob wins with a tie. Okay example
What are we uh example Oh example category
So I would say human touch so you buzz in when you know the category human touch
magic
wrecking ball
tunnel of love
being born yes springsteen
Springsteen album names. Yes, springsteen album names. Yeah, I think I think Paul would have gotten that the next one was born to run
And the last one was Nebraska
Okay, all right
Alright, I get it. I get it. Okay. Alright, so that's the game. So here we go. Here's the here's the first real one
You buzz in when you know it
Arizona
Idaho
Oregon
Utah
California ding ding Paul Southwest States incorrect Matt you get a free guess
West of the Mississippi
Now I'm afraid that's not it either
Also, that was all the words. So there aren't any more hints to give
It's uh states that border, Nevada
States that border Nevada. It's that let's see nobody
Correctly, Jacob gets to make fun of you for long or as long as he sees fit you guys suck at naming states that border, Nevada
Okay, that's it. That's enough. This is true. Next one offer
OFF er
Gagging
Object work Oh
buzz
Matt improv terms
Improv terminology. Absolutely. That's a point for Matt Donnelly. What's gagging?
Gagging is like a go for jokes. Yeah go for joking. Yeah. Okay. Yeah
Yeah, I like to like choke it back a little bit like
It's a classic drop it is let's see strange world
Battleship
Mortal engines
ding
Yes box office flops
box office bombs, absolutely
Let's see mortal engines the adventures of Pluto Nash John Carter
Waterworld the 13th warrior and the Lone Ranger. I can't like category warrior bombed. That's ridiculous. It's terrible movie
No, it's not. It's really good. Oh, man
We're just so bad though. I've ever seen that theaters are going like all the effects are terrible. Oh, I don't know. I liked it
bear eagle
Tiger's professional sports teams names that are our animals sports ball animals. Yep
mmm, and
Oh two more the natural the first the pelican the granite
the silver
the golden
the aloha
Mmm, I'll start from the beginning. Yeah the natural the first
pelican
the beaver
the granite
the silver
the golden and the aloha ding
Yes
pubic hairstyles
All right, oh
Sorry, I'm leaving out one there's also the show me oh
Buzz go ahead the state nicknames
State nicknames is it? Yep. The natural states first date pelican state, etc. Last one guy was right
What did you say?
Cupid hairstyles
Yeah, all right. We're tied two to two
That's not the answer. We were looking for that time, but I mean, it's also those are also
I'm looking for
last one the talon
double R
Nervosa in you RV o sa nervosa Luke's
Monks
Bing yes, Paul
fictional coffee shops from sitcoms or TV shows
Fictional coffee shops is it the last one was central perk such a that would have put it over the edge for all of us
Yeah, I hope you had as much fun as I had making it. That's winter scoop. Thank you so much winter scoop
What a fun game
That was a great categories. Yeah, really fun. That's really fun one like that
Hey scoops comm go over to hey scoops comm you can do
Any of these types of things you can send us some email you can send us a price of scryte jock versus nerd an obelisk jock versus nerd
A scooperty do all the things over there. Hey scoops comm
Please do guys. That was good. Yeah
Thank you winter scoop. That was good
I want to thank I want to thank you gentlemen to complain about me on the princess cruise ship for
Putting you in your place. Not all heroes wear capes finally got knocked down a few pegs Donnelly
Thank you everyone who could join us here for for a hang on. Yeah guys. Thanks for sticking around
Absolutely
I'm gonna think punch left great in this podcast
Thanks, Ben and one of these people here who all support us over here on patreon. Here are their names now
That's right. We're going to put their names in later or you're going to hear me saying this
number down
Don't worry about it
Yes
And if you want to join that list of names head on over to preaching fun comm and support us today
Or if you've ever waited in line to complain about the entertainment to somebody who did not care about it
But then the entertainer was standing right there next to you go to farts in a bag dot biz and connect with Matt Donnelly
He wants to meet you
That's farts in a bag dot biz that along with preaching fun comm it takes you over to our patreon page where for as little as
Three dollars a month you can help keep this show on the air. We are
Independent on our patreon supporters. So please if you think this show is worth more than zero dollars
Which is all it's been worth to you so far head over to preaching fun comm farts in a bag dot biz
Sign up today. You can do a full year-round subscription. You save a little bit of money if you do the year-round subscription
You can also it's the holiday times
If you want to gift someone a subscription, you can gift them a subscription to our show
They can add free version of the show. They get all kinds of stuff. They get cool hangs with us online
Yeah, it's a it's a whole barrel of monkeys
Signing up over there at preaching fun comm and farts in a bag dot biz
Thanks for this everybody. Stay safe out there. We love you and we'll see you soon
You
That was the world's greatest car we're preaching fun see ya